hello everyone
welcome to this video tutorial on sql vs
nosql by simplynoun
in this session we will learn about sql
what is relational database
and then have a look at what is nosql
and non-relational database
after knowing both these technologies we
will compare both
and see when to use sql 9 when to use
nosql
then we will have a look at the
companies using these technologies
so hey everyone i am abhisara uja from
simply learn
and welcome to this video on sql vs
nosql
but before we begin if you love watching
tech videos subscribe to our channel and
hit the bell icon to never miss an
update
first we will have a look on what is sql
sql is the standard language for dealing
with relational databases
sql can be used to insert search update
and delete database records sql can do
lots of other operations
including optimizing and maintenance of
databases
sql stands for structured query language
pronounced as
sql or sometimes as sql relational
databases like mysql database
oracle mysql server sybase etc use
ansi sql after understanding what is sql
let's have a look at relational database
a database is a set of data stored in a
computer
this data is usually structured in a way
that makes the data easily accessible
a relational database is a type of
database it uses a structure
that allows us to identify nss data in
relation to another piece of data in the
database
often data in a relational database is
organized into tables
a relational database management system
rdbms is a program
that allows you to create update and
administer a relational database
most relational database management
systems use the sql language
to assess the database sql syntax may
differ slightly depending on which rdbms
you are using
let's see some popular rdms mysql
mysql is the most popular open source
sql database
it is typically used for web application
development and often assessed using php
possibly sql postgresql is an open
source sql database that is not
controlled by any corporation
it is typically used for web application
development oracle database
oracle corporation owns oracle database
and the code is not open source
oracle database is for large
applications particularly in the banking
industry
sql server microsoft owns sql server
like oracle database the code is close
sourced
large enterprise applications mostly use
sql server
sqlite sqlite is an open source
sql database it can store an entire
database in a single file
one of the most significant advantages
this provides is that all of the data
can be stored locally without having to
connect to database to a server
now we shift to nosql nosql
is a non-relational data management
system that does not require a fixed
schema
it avoids joins and is easy to scale
the major purpose of using a nosql
database is for distributed data
as to store this data we need humongous
data storage
nosql is used for big data and real-time
web apps
for example companies like twitter
facebook and google collect
terabytes of user data every single day
nosql database stands for not only sql
or node sql
karl strozz introduced the nosql concept
in 1998.
traditional rdbms uses sql syntax to
store and retrieve data for further
insights
instead a nosql database system
encompasses a wide range of database
technologies
that can store structured
semi-structured unstructured and
polymorphic data
non-relational databases are often used
when large quantities of complex
and diverse data need to be organized
for example
a large store might have a database in
which each customer has their own
document
containing all of the information from
name and address
to order history and credit card
information despite their differing
formats
each of these pieces of information can
be stored in the same document
some popular non-relational database
systems are
neo4j radis mongodb cassandra
apache actress after understanding both
the technologies we will head for the
comparison
the first point we will consider is
definition sql databases
are primarily called rdbms or relational
databases
nosql databases are primarily called as
non-relational or distributed database
the next point is query language sql
stands for structured query language
and this is the standard language when
we talk about sql
but when we talk about nosql no sql
databases have no declarative query
language to work with
this brings us to the next point that is
type
sql databases are table based databases
tables from the backbone of this entity
but when we come to nosql it includes
everything
nosql databases can be document based
key value pairs
graph databases and much more the next
point is scalability
sql databases are vertically scalable
and can be stacked on one another
whereas nosql is horizontally scalable
the next point is usage sequel is an
ideal choice for the complex query
intensive environment
but when it comes to nosql it's a little
left behind
as it is not good for it for complex
queries
the next point is open source in sql
there is a mix of
open source like postgre sql and mysql
and commercials like oracle database but
when we come to nosql
that ever since open source the next
point is
principal mode sql follows acid model
which is
atomicity consistency isolation and
durability
when coming to nosql we have base model
basically available
soft state eventually consistent after
comparing both sql and nosql let's see
when to use sql
sql is used when analyzing behavior
related tasks and when you have to give
any customized sessions for your clients
and
sql is the preferred language used to
communicate with the rdms
it is also used for building custom
dashboards the main use is
when you have to store and get data from
the database quickly
the last one for sql is sql is preferred
when you want to use joins
and execute complex queries
now we'll see when to use nosql nosql is
used when your data does not require
acid support to work with and you can
use base properties to work with
and nosql is used when traditional rdbms
model is not enough
we use non-relational database as nosql
came to fulfill the words of sql
also nosql gives an advantage as it is
used when data needs a flexible schema
and another advantage of nosql is it is
used when constraints and validation
logics
are not required to be implemented in a
database the most important point is
nosql is used when logging data from
distributed sources
now we'll see some big companies using
sql that is microsoft
dell cognizant stack overflow entity
data
and accenture now let's see companies
using nosql
that is amazon jp morgan adobe
capgemini qualcomm and sap with that we
have come to the end of this session
i hope it was interesting and
informative if you liked it please let
us know in the comment
section also do subscribe to our channel
and stay tuned for more from simpler
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here